[Music]
it's the most Christmas is a magical
time full of wonder excitement enjoy a
time for making lasting memories with
family and friends do you know the
secret behind what makes Christmas so
special mom's mom's working their asses
off cookie wrapping decorating and
shopping from like November to New
Year's this is our busiest time of the
year of work I waxed 39 [ __ ] today
who's next
oh my god since one of every woman in
America need a completely hairless
vagina on Christmas I spent months
picking out the perfect present for
everyone you know the only thing I get
in return
coupons for free back rubs that's not
okay
shitty back rubs remember when the
holidays were actually fun hey Christmas
back come on where's your tree I didn't
waste time Christmas tree shopping I
actually just wanted to enjoy Christmas
this year
Amy you're a mom moms don't and joy they
give joy that's helping a mom works
[Music]
no the house that's really nice
thank you your dad is awesome thank you
needed him why would you say that I
heard you and Daddy in the bedroom
you kept singing those were just there
were happy screams and then you punch
the wall and yell the effort you were
like [ __ ] you God just like that oh my
[ __ ] god my [ __ ] door
[Music]
[Music]
you